way i want to take the temperature of
boston
two days after tommy
goes not tommy curran tommy brady goes
to tampa
and he's one for one wins a super bowl
in his first year with the team what's
the overall
mood in boston in response to that
achievement
boy as with any place that's a little
bit tribal
there is a sense of ownership in that
i'm pissed off to see tom brady having
that kind of fun someplace else he's our
guy
and we're his guys and this pisses us
off there's another segment that is
very irritated that this is still
an elite level quarterback by virtually
every measure
and now the patriots who had him
in house and basically held the door for
him to walk out of house
are in the market for a quarterback when
this guy was still good and now he's in
tampa bay and then there's another group
i think another segment
of the population which is mostly loyal
to the new england patriots
and as a result point out that that
wasn't going to happen if he was here
because it's not a good enough team a
and b are you meaning or all he's done
here
is that what you're doing son so there's
those three factions
tom i didn't go to the super bowl for
the first time since february of 1994
but if i had my choice
of where i wanted to watch the super
bowl on sunday it would not have been in
tampa
it would be would have been at bill
belichick's house or wherever he watched
the super bowl
you know belichick as well as anyone
what do you think he was
thinking watching that game do you think
he was rooting for tom brady
yeah i think yeah i would imagine that
he was rooting for tom brady
although he does have a great affinity
for andy reid and a great friendship
so i don't know if rooney interest
enters into it
but for everything that brady would have
done well in that game guys i think that
he would have said yeah well
i mean what do you expect we knew we
could throw the football i mean we know
he's smart
it's not like we didn't know these
things it's just everything else that
came with it
it's not getting ridiculous here um but
i think
you know deep down i don't think that
the pressure
bill belichick is under could have been
ratcheted up anymore because he is that
kind of a
type a person but i think ownership
probably
has its attention peaked right now
because
this is worst case scenario for the
franchise
and mike they had two videos they had a
tweet ready and then they had a video
ready monday
that was entitled simply the quest with
matthew slater
narrating that the patriots are all
about winning and there
they won't rest until they're back to
winning
it's very much in response to what the
tom brady did
yeah obviously and that puts even more
pressure on bill belichick
and the front office and ownership to
make a move at quarterback
that allows them to feel like they've
got
something you can't just hang around and
wait for a bargain basement opportunity
like
late june cam newton falls into your lap
you got to do something you got to make
a statement do they feel that urgency do
you believe because i think from the
outside i look at i say hey look
your move bill belichick you got to do
something at quarterback and it can't be
jared stidham
it can't be cam newton and it definitely
can't be brian hoyt
100 they feel the urgency but i don't
think that they want to get caught into
a situation where
here let's make a mistake like say
drafting
i don't know jp waspin's level
quarterback
just to satiate people who want to see a
quarterback coming because now you've
dug yourself
another three-year whole so
esther at the quarterback position i
don't think belichick is of a mind that
look just to satiate the masses here i'm
gonna go and sign
or draft mac jones and and sign mitch
trubisky
if he doesn't think that's the right
thing to do i still think that he will
foot dragon say
i know more about what wins in the nfl
now and i still do
than anybody else hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports